it's an image as old as time a baby
swaddled in white delivered by the stork
how quaint but you'll find here on stork
mountain we take baby delivery seriously
I'm here to finally unveil our new and
improved human infant production
facility we have perfected and
streamlines the process devising a zero
mistake workflow red mark using the most
cutting-edge technology coupled with
over 75 years of hard-won experience our
new process has been described as
perfect precise flawless appeal
immaculate no problemo
era truth to betrayal the opposite of
the Titanic yes
we work hard just so you can hear the
four most precious words in human
language googoo gah-gah so when you're
looking for baby delivery you can come
home Castorp delivery service make a
plan stick to the plan for what is doing
ah what was that oh no my bad
Oh
she's talking in her sleep
Deutsch there's a lot of things in her
sleep okay I'm in the ratchet wrench I
can fix it yeah what if she starts sleep
swimming again